à la moindre étincelle tout peut
s'embraser cette colonne de sapin c'est
broussailles très sèche aussi alors les
pompiers se battent sans relâche
derrière sept buts un brasier
impressionnant
quatorze mille tonnes de fourrage
partent en fumée
on a sur ma droite le premier bâtiment
de 2500 m² de fourrage entièrement
rempli donc qui est entièrement en train
de brûler et puis plus de ce côté là sur
la gauche on va le bâtiment de 9000 m² à
usage de stockage de fourrages de bétail
et de matériels agricoles sur lesquelles
on a environ 7000 m² qui brûle tout
brûle depuis cette nuit
il est une heure du matin quand
l'incendié se déclare dans ces bâtiments
agricoles très vite
trente cinq engins 80 pompiers sont
mobilisés
l'objectif évacuer 60 bovins prise au
piège et protéger le bâtiment où est
stocké le fioul ce matin le propriétaire
est abattu il n'aura pas les mots pour
décrire des mois de travail détruit ce
voisin lui aussi a veillé toute la nuit
je suis arrivé ici à 1h30 2h donc il y
avait tout bâtiment là qu'ils étaient en
train de cramer complètement
on a sorti un peu de matériel au cas où
nos bâtiments prenez aussi parce qu'on
n'avait pas tellement envie que tout
crin non plus comment expliquer ce
départ de feu
les enquêteurs n'écartent aucune
hypothèse mais c'est bien la piste
criminelle qui est envisagée avec
beaucoup de conviction selon les mots du
parquet un incendie avec des dégâts
humains aussi dans la nuit un pompier a
chuté lourdement
nous l'avons pris en charge bien
évidemment et transféré sur le centre
hospitalier françois mitterrand à dijon
mais son état là encore est très
satisfaisant puisqu'il est sorti de
l'hôpital en cours de matinée une
douzaine de pompiers va rester sur place
ce soir et dans les prochains jours pour
éviter que le feu ne se propage aux
alentours car le fourrage lui va mettre
plusieurs jours a brûlé entièrement
une enquête de gendarmerie a été ouverte
pour déterminer les circonstances
précises de l'incendié